welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is
hisham azuz today i'm really excited to
be joined by russell hughes
who is a partner at the fjr group
russell has worked in the industry since
2003
in that time russell progressed from
consultant all the way to
associate director within the large
corporate robert half
he then later become managing director
of their executive search europe
function
before then leaving to join the fjr
group and over the last three years
russell has been focused on helping the
fjr group grow
and within the london division and they
have
offices in london manchester with a
footprint in america and scotland
and the fjr group are on a mission to be
in 25 locations globally within
25 years russ thanks for for joining me
thanks for having me good to be here
really looking forward to this so
where we always like to start the
million pound question
in your opinion what what
characteristics and traits do you think
make up a
highly successful recruitment consultant
that is a million dollar question isn't
it because that's what everyone wants to
find out the answer to when you're
hiring but um
for me i think that there's some common
commonalities and i think
over the years having worked with hired
and
with with some fantastic people and they
could be like
out and out sales people to very reserve
concert
conservative consultative people i think
that the common trait for me
is that is the quality of the questions
people ask
and the ability to to listen and really
hear what
what people are saying to you um so i
think it
packaged up it's your communication
skills um
but i think for me it's probably in
essence yeah it's your ability to ask
good questions and your ability to
build rapport and relationships but
equally to
to listen carefully to what people are
telling you and understand
you know what what their real reasons
and motives for doing things are
yeah i love that yeah it's kind of it's
come up a couple of times but
being curious is yeah inquisitive yeah
yeah
definitely genuinely as well like
wanting to not because it's like right
someone asked questions then i can
talk to them about this candidate or
whatever it's generally having interest
and trying to understand
yeah yeah the problems and potential
solutions that you can
help clients candidates with absolutely
um
so obviously quite quite a bit to unpack
here right so obviously
for for those listening how we're
thinking about this is
so obviously you spent a lot a large
chunk of your recruitment career robert
half
and then for the last obviously yeah
just over three years
you've been uh helping grow the fjr
group so
let's just first touch on your sort of
journey at robert half
right obviously robert half household
name um obviously that wasn't your
first recruitment job so talk to us
about like your first year in
recruitment i'm always interested in
that so
you've actually been company first year
yeah first year in recruitment so
obviously got your first job look like i
don't know if that what if you would say
that worked out or it didn't work out
but you then ended up
robert half like what was your first
year in recruitment the first the first
year was interesting because i'd come
um i've been away traveling for a little
bit came back
and whilst i've been away i've met a guy
who'd
who was just chatting to that had worked
in recruitment when he was in sydney
and it just sounded quite interesting
but i wasn't looking for that when i
came back i kind of moved to london and
wanted a job
in sales and i think my main criteria
then was i wanted a company car that was
what is in the back of my head
and they had to come back why did you
want a job in sales that that's not
common
well i think one i didn't i wanted
something that was
going to give me an ability to impact my
earnings first and foremost i didn't
want to be restrained by how much i
could earn through
um a sort of functional role that would
um you know limit you and perhaps have
hierarchy that stopped you getting where
you wanted to get to more
more quickly so that was the that was
the reason for sales i always felt like
i was
well i can't hear you for some reason
just quickly
no come on two seconds
it looked like it was on mute for some
reason that's just yeah it says
we can hear fine now so what you're
saying so
yeah so sales i guess for me just seemed
like a natural fit i um
you know what is something that was
going to allow me to earn as much as
possible
as quickly as possible um and so that
was kind of
the plan came back and started applying
for sales jobs and
the recruitment business that i first
joined had
invited me in to register me and whilst
there was
chatting to them about um
just generally talking and the guy
started asking me questions
about what i wanted to do and i was
asking him questions about what he did
and talking about the guy met in
sydney that had done recruitment and and
slowly literally started bringing other
people in to meet with me and then
you know by the end of the session they
sort of said well would you consider a
job in recruitment and
and that was kind of how it happened but
the first um
first year was interesting so i've not
done anything like that
um and my first day with the business
it was sales recruitments we were
placing sales people the first day in
the business they um
i remember walking in into an office
with 20 or so people and
sat down at a desk with um
a cv of a guy who sold photocopiers and
uh and i was given a list
of a list of companies from an
exhibition that was going on at the
excel center and that was generally how
you
we seemed to find companies to call and
then i was given a script
to follow to call up and try and speak
to
sales directors and pitch this candidate
who sold photocopiers
into them and the objective was to try
and get
a sort of interview for that candidate
closed off there and then on the phone
um and it was just yeah heavily kpi'd
you never met any clients were
candidates it was purely
like teddy sales i guess you just got
yeah every day you'd come in
you'd you'd um get a cv of someone you'd
find a list of people to call and you
just go out and it was you know 600
calls a week 120 of the day and
19 or 12 you were on the phone if you
weren't you were
getting beasted and um two till five so
it was
it was definitely interesting and i
think after after you've done that for a
period of time you just start
questioning
you know what have we ever met some of
these clients and got in front of them
do you think we might get
them call us with some jobs rather than
just chasing um
interviews for candidates each and every
day so i guess you start
do you just start questioning it that
was their model and it worked and you
could make really good money doing it
but it wasn't overly
um it was a bit soul-destroying after a
while
and i think yeah i just um i sort of
outgrew that and just felt like there
was there's got to be a better way of
doing things and
um that led me to yeah start searching
for something else but knowing that i
quite enjoyed recruitment but
i think i wanted to be someone that was
able to get out and meet people and
and that had stopped me doing it have
that face to face yeah yeah do you
think like just talking about that do
you think like if you
do you think that approach would work in
today's market no
but yes you've got to think about
there's nuances of your market right but
over if we were to say like a holistic
view or like just a
general food do we think that would work
i think i think it could
because i think just the sheer volume of
what you're doing
and i think you you do you're not
following the script clearly after a
hundred times of doing it yeah and you
start to listen and if you do
start to ask good questions then you can
start to build rapport and relationships
and you will
you know naturally if you do a good job
for someone they will likely start to
think of you
and come back to you but it's not but
getting out and meeting them i think has
a
masses of benefit but but i think it
clearly could work but it's not
i think you should it's a it has a life
cycle i think people
want to want to progress and feel like
they're progressing and that is very
regimented very disciplined each and
every day to do the same thing and
you know you just paint my numbers and
if you if you do it you can
you can make money but not everyone does
this job just to make money you might do
that initially but maybe that's not
everything is a real motivator for doing
it so
yeah it probably could i think it does
give you some grounding and
you know some skills that can transfer
into
your later career because yeah that
ability to
make something happen literally and
close people down is um
you know that's a good skill to have but
i think it i think there's different
ways to do stuff now
um and i found it really tough actually
going from that into
robert half in the first um
you know the first first three months or
so i found it really difficult because
one it was a different mark
your sales people and accountants are
quite different people
in a lot of in most instances
that was really quite a challenge to
temper and change my
way of doing things from the way i've
been taught to
you know a different business all
together in a different type of
individual that you're dealing with
yeah i can imagine and just really
quickly just to get
really practical and you can draw on any
yeah just your overall
experience here but just uh curious to
ask
what would you say are your like
non-negotiables now
when speccing out candidates like just
out of interest because that's where you
obviously you're just talking about how
you started you did a lot of that so i
feel like
you'll have like a probably solid
process framework that
you use or you try and share with your
colleagues like what
like if you've got a candidate that's
got a really good skill set
that you know good select for your
businesses would probably want to know
about
and you're targeting them what what's
what's your framework
yeah i don't know actually i'm i'd
probably i think you just got to
highlight all of that i think you've got
to highlight the value that they're
going to add and draw upon the
you know clearly it's got to be relevant
to to start with um
yeah industry you know role um and
you've got i think you've got to
just draw upon the value out of the
person that you're specking out you
gotta have
got a really good understanding of where
they've added significant value and i
think if you're then targeting
um specifically targets in a business or
a person where
you know there's some change going on or
you've heard something and you're you
know
people can't help but then stop and
listen if you've if you've if you've
done your research and you're specking
someone out that
you know genuinely could add value then
yeah and you're
talking through why they're gonna have
value i can't think that many are gonna
even if they really don't want it there
and then you know they're gonna they're
gonna recognize that
you've come to them with something that
could have benefited them yeah fair
enough obviously yeah you've got to know
your market and have that sort of
insight and
like what i used to do was um we'd
always
basically we'd always put down like
three to five bullet points
max on what you just said on like how
we understand that they this candidate
could potentially add value to that
business
yeah and our goal was to like get
through that and then just our
end with luck and open questions like
how how open would you be to
booking in the time to discuss this
person forever or whatever
um so just interested if you if you
started with some sort of script that
you're just
nailing down i was just interested to
see how it's evolved or
definitely no no script anymore i think
because yeah
i had that i've i've done lots of
scripts and i'm not i'm not a fan of it
so
no i don't think so i think i think you
just kind of that's probably inherently
built into me
in some way that you just yeah maybe
maybe i've not thought about it enough
but maybe you do
just have a way of doing it that would i
think i'd probably yeah yeah i mean you
got to recognize that the moment you
call them you're probably interrupting
them and
you kind of gotta you know probably be
open and honest about why you're calling
i think that's
always what you got through to the
decision maker that's always worked well
i think if you just
are up front the look is a sales call um
and then if you you know if you're
reasoning like you say if you've got two
or three bullet points about
why that person could potentially add
value yeah
probably yeah it wouldn't be dissimilar
to that yeah fair enough
interesting so let's talk about so you
mentioned it there so
then joined robert half obviously
completely different
obviously environment business to what
you initially um
found yourself in so like
what what i'm interested to know
obviously a lot of recruiters
um want to progress they want to get to
that director level etcetera so i guess
just the sort of first question i have
for you really is like
why and i'm sure robert half that is
competitive
there's high standards and these types
of things like
why do you think you was able to get to
that a.d
position compared to your peers and the
people sitting next to you that no doubt
a lot of them were trying to get to as
well
um i think that um
there's not i mean there's not too many
career paths are there in recruitment
you are the bill when are really good at
it and you enjoy doing that or you try
and go down the leadership route and i
think
to do the leadership thing you've got to
one be
probably pushing for it but but busy
enough
that you could have people around you
and and help them get to where they want
to get to
and not be some of the best regulars
i've met
are just out and out billers and just
want to make loads of money but they're
too
they're a bit too selfish to be able to
share some of that somewhat to
to help those around them and i think
that you've got to want to go down the
leadership route first and foremost but
i think for me it was about being
busy enough and and successful enough in
my billing to start with to know
um and just to have a
i want to help people around me i think
so i think you naturally start
doing that without perhaps having the
job or the title first
and as you go through that it just it
sort of more naturally comes to you i
think it
i was definitely knocking on the door to
want to manage people
because i saw that as you know that was
how i measured the progression
once i got billing sorted then that
would be in my head how i thought about
i was progressing within the business so
and then i would just yeah i'd be
knocking on the door i want to do this i
want to do this and
and i would be who is you knocking on
the door of
out of interest uh different people at
different times through the career but
but
i'd work with neil who i work with now
obviously for a huge part of my career
so i remember
trying to trying to become a division
manager i guess that's the first run
within robert half was
you know i had to i took him i was
knocking on neil's door for quite a
while to do that and he kept um
he kept push me back and say until i was
i think he
i think he really wanted me to be
certain that i wanted to do that because
it's uh i think i think it can be a
tough job when you
you go through once you that that
for the first leadership role one you've
got to kind of give up a proportion of
your time to help others
which could potentially impact your own
earnings through performance yeah
through your performance so
you've kind of you do have to want to do
it and i think that
he he sort of kept fending me off a
little bit not for a massive period of
time but but did
sort of push me back a couple of times i
guess just tested your commitment and
yeah
yeah and i think then once you once you
get into it you kind of
if you if you're really
you've got to work hard i guess to
understand the people around you their
motivators what what pushes their
buttons why they're doing what what
their why is why they're doing it
because that can help you link in you
know performance and
the need to do certain activities that
will help them get where they need to
get to but
um yeah i think it's it's definitely a
tough job that first
that first leadership role and when
you've got two three four people around
you that
are um you know especially they've got
not a lot of experience
it takes up a lot of your time and that
can
impact your your own earnings for a bit
but i guess you've got to take balance
that with
um if you get over that then you know
your earnings
you come back again and you're in a
different different place then
so i'm gonna ask you on on around that
like
because we hear this a lot that's a
really difficult part of
if you do want to progress that way with
your recruitment career that is a really
difficult patch and some
people may find themselves in the sort
of billing leadership capacity for
some time so i'm keen to ask you where
you think
like maybe some recruiters go wrong with
that or
what maybe you had to learn the hard way
but really quickly because i think
this has been shared a couple of times
uh which i think is really important to
highlight most recruiters listening to
this will be people that do want to
progress and want to maximize their
their career
and i just want to highlight the amount
that you
really went above and beyond to make
sort of the relevant people aware that
you wanted to
you wanted that position i think
sometimes that's what people can miss
out on
i feel like yeah i think people can slip
into like hey
likes i don't know people may be sitting
next to you and going i
i thought i would be the best person to
do that job but they expected it to come
to them
to get what i'm in i think that's the
challenge isn't it i think yeah
if you wait for it to come to you a lot
of the time it won't
sometimes it could but i think a lot of
the time it won't and i think you've
gotta
you gotta make it happen so i think that
i think
when i when i was at half the 2009
i had gone off and taken a sabbatical
and went and did some travel and came
back
yeah when i came back i'd i'd previously
been working on a
team that did sort of front office
corporate finance m a recruitment and
um i came back and needed to go back
onto the finance and accounting area
again within financial services
but it was a much smaller team obviously
the lehman's thing the markets crashed
and
so it was a very different um landscape
and i think
there was a few a couple of us on the
team at the time but
all who maybe had some designs on
wanting to be the person that
potentially led that division going
forward
um and there wasn't no one was told
right well you're leading it it was kind
of you you sort of had to make it happen
so
it's probably the best example really
but so i
there was a couple of there was a few of
us on there and some of them really it
was a tough market anyway but everyone
kind of
had to be able to make money but i just
i really put my foot down on on
trying to hire and trying to knock on
their ass i've just found this person we
need to
can you interview them see what you
think and i'd and i'd just ask
everyone and anyone i knew who do you
know that would be good at recruitment i
was i hired a couple of my old pals from
school that i hadn't seen for a long
time
um i'd you know just any opportunity to
try and think outside the box of your
typical just
you know you've recruited with the years
two years experience i was just
looking at people who had transferable
skills and i think if someone is
you know like we talked about the outset
inquisitive um
great communication skills good good at
questioning
um can build rapport um has a good
energy about them
i would i would ask them about it i'll
talk to them do you have you ever
thought about doing recruitment as
the guy that i've met years ago in
sydney had asked me and i think that um
through then bringing them in and just
even though i hadn't
been given license to maybe hire someone
at the time i'd just bring them in as a
good person and if i thought they were
great
i'd try and get my boss to meet them as
well and before you know it you've got
you know you've hired one and then
if you get them slowly you know if
you're still quite busy and you can get
them ingrained into the
the wider group and they start making a
bit of money then you know you're
knocking at the door again with someone
else and i think that
you kind of just make it happen yourself
and i think that and when
i've seen other people do that as well i
think you just got to if you really want
it
you've got to go and make it happen and
and not wait but i think if you've got
your own performance sorted and you
could
give his you know there's there's enough
rhyme and reason that you're going to be
able to help someone else get successful
then
who's going to say no to that because
ultimately you're not going to meet many
recruitment business owners that don't
want to grow
and i think that if you can show that
you you're growing
your business is growing and you're you
know you're finding them people where
you're not having to pay a fee for them
potentially through other
other you know rec directs them why not
yeah for sure so i think so i think few
things are underlined there for people
listening there's one
you've mentioned it a couple of times
now already but what you're
demonstrating there is the
sort of willingness to do aspects of the
role that you're
that you want in the future before
you've actually got it
yeah right so you mentioned that before
you was helping other people doing those
things
before you was in some sort management
but was willing and sort of
demonstrating that
then you just obviously talking about an
example there where you sort of
you knew how important it was or how
difficult it was to actually hire people
for the team so went out of your way to
see if there was
people that you could bring in and doing
all that and then all of a sudden then
you're
the person that's knocking on the door
going hey this is why i want to do it
this is the opportunity that i want and
also by the way these are all the things
that i've done in the meantime
yeah you're gonna have a way better
chance of being told that you're getting
that promotion over the person that
is just relying on i don't know their
performance billings and then
relying on people coming to them going
hey russ like should we talk about you
becoming a manager
right yeah i think yeah so i think it's
a mixture of those things being
proactive letting people know where you
want to
be um whilst also being willing to do
the role
or aspects of the role and showing those
things before you actually get it
yeah i think you've got to be prepared
to do that you've got to be prepared to
do the job before you before you've got
the job
um yeah i think if you can demonstrate
that then you're more likely to be the
one that gets it yeah
so so on this really quickly then so
like just really quickly i want to make
sure
i ask it so like if i'm someone that's
listening i know they want to go into
leadership
position i'm knocking on the door i'm
doing something that there's
extra activities that hopefully will
yeah give me even more merit with my
leader or the person that can make the
decision
what what do i need to be aware of then
um
that could potentially hurt my
performance or i might find really
challenging because you mentioned it a
few times and
it seems like there's this bit of a
balancing act going on on your
performance
getting the most out of your new highs
or in that leadership like
where do you where do people typically
go wrong or where where should people
expect to
find it really difficult in that
transition i think i think when you get
going you've got to kind of think
learning what makes you good at
recruiting
is a if you've got that nailed down
because i think that not everyone does
it the same way i think once you get to
a point where you
are given a bit of freedom to just get
on and do the job everyone finds their
way
um and everyone has their own kind of
intimate style and i think
if you have um i found that quite
challenging to begin with because i
i think a lot of recruiters are not very
good at i wasn't very good at being
overly
um organized on our database or putting
stuff on the system and i just find that
you know you have stuff in your head or
you know where you're going and that i
think
was something i needed to learn a little
more but being able to
know what makes you good to help try and
show someone else how to be good
um is the first point i think the second
point is when you do
start managing people and you're still
having to be very
focused on production yourself it's
about being um
respecting your own time to do your job
that you're doing
which is performance related and i think
you know setting some
boundaries with those around you that
you are leading is
um is critical and i think it's easy to
get sucked into
um you know answering questions or
getting pulled pulled off desk
or to help with something that's not
necessarily business critical
that you that impacts your time and your
ability to be
productive yourself and i think if you
can you know if
if it's business critical then grab me
talk to me about it but between you know
at these points i think we need you know
i need some time
write down what you want to find the
answer to and then we'll come back to it
at lunchtime you know end the day
whatever it is but if it's business
critical grab me now but i think you've
got to you've got to respect your own
time
and the need to perform yourself whilst
in a billing plus leading role
yeah interesting okay um and then
real quick one have you
as you were sort of going up um the sort
of
ladder as you were and just sort of
progressing have you ever
sort of had to deal with sort of
feelings of
imposter syndrome out of interest
uh
i don't i don't i don't think so i think
um maybe
you ever feel like how have i got ahead
i might
like yeah i haven't yeah like sort of
internalizing
they're not doubting that you've got
their own merit or you've had
i don't know yeah and then i don't know
i think maybe i think because i was with
robert half for so long
and i think it was you know steady
progression i was kind of running my own
race so i don't think that
yeah yeah um i don't think i felt it
there i think if i'd have if i'd have
you know done
there's people that you know go quicker
and go faster
and go bigger in other companies that um
i think if you may be moving from
you know one company to another and then
you've suddenly landed a big
you know job that you i think you i
could see how that could happen but
i think mine was i was kind of almost
protected in my own head because
it was it was steady progression and it
was within the same company so i think
that
um you know up until then it was pretty
i don't i don't think i massively ever
suffered from that but i can see how
that can
can happen yeah yeah um but i think yeah
because of
the environment sure so
on on this then before we move on to um
fjr so i'm just interested so robert
half obviously huge
household name like in your in your
opinion like why why do you think
they've become what they've become
out of interest like why have they
become such a
big brand in the recruitment industry
out of interest i guess i'm i'm curious
about the culture i'm curious about
what sort of culture i don't know yeah
that's what i'm interested in
i think um i think they do a lot of
things really really well
i don't think you know for me i had an
amazing time there i've got i'm not even
bad to say about it i think that you
know for
for me the experience was in the in the
main
positive the whole time i think if you
if you were
that you know there were high standards
when when i joined there was definitely
high standards for
you know production for you know trying
to climb the ladder it was um
but it was an environment that did allow
people
to progress it allowed people to
flourish i think if you worked hard and
you
you did the right things that
opportunity was there and because it's a
big company you do have
opportunities to move and travel a bit
with it but um
i think they yeah i just think they do a
lot of things right they um
they're helped by the fact that the the
standards are high and the
inputs that are expected are high so i
think that if people are getting close
to reaching those you're
you know you're naturally gonna you're
naturally gonna win business because
you're really busy and you're doing a
lot of
a lot of work um and i think that they
they they try to to train people
to coach people so i think there's they
give a lot back
i think that it's difficult to just
define it down to one or two things
isn't it
um i think they do a lot of stuff well
yeah how how did you
remain motivated russ in your career do
you think
i feel like that's part of why i ended
up moving and stuff we spoke about
i'm just interested because i feel like
a lot of recruiters faces that i speak
to especially
recruiters that progress well and and
and achieve success is like i don't know
like there's sort of peaks and troughs
of motivation because you
you really climbed the ladder you ended
up being lady then
left and came back like how how did you
remain
motivated i think you're right there are
peaks and troughs and i think that you
reach
i think i think i think i think you've
got to run your own race i think you
kind of
you can't you can't necessarily compare
yourself the whole time to other people
because that's a recipe for
um for maybe feeling a bit crap
yeah i don't know you just got to um you
got to run your own race i think that
there's different
things that will happen in your life
that will motivate you at different
points for me
there was a you know lots of fun and and
excitement on going on the journey
initially
and wanting to climb the ladder and
wanting to you know try different things
and then
you know settling down and having a
family gave me a completely different
motivation to want to
one you know provide for your family to
to
have more time with your family and that
probably led me to thinking about
changing companies um after
having been there a long time i wanted a
bit more balance and flexibility and
um and so i think that i think there's
just at different points in my life
there's been different things that have
motivated me i think the beginning
it was money material things
you know more recently it's been you
know time um
balance in life um not just having it
all
work related but having you know a lot
of stuff going on that's kind of work
and i think that
that's helped me to reframe what it is
that gets me up and out
doing what i do each day and i think
obviously what you're talking about
there is is self-awareness right and
being able like how how often
i don't know do you find yourself
checking in with yourself quite
a lot on it because obviously
understanding that is just super
important right
especially in recruitment the the highs
and lows that you face it's just
really important i think that's
something i could have done better on is
just having a really strong anchor point
of like why i'm doing what i'm doing
yeah and you hear this a lot like how is
this something that you sort of try and
check him with
every couple of weeks you do things
yourself i don't know
just curious i don't i don't if i do it
so consciously as that
to stop every couple of weeks and um i
think
i think i think i've always been pretty
good at compartmentalizing
areas of my life so i think that um
whilst work was a
certainly you know the first 10 years or
so behalf i was so
focused on where i was trying to get to
that that consumed me i also
met my now wife when i was working there
so you know that made life easier
because we'd better go out together
after work and you know socialize with
everyone we'd be able to go for it you
know
we didn't have kids yet so it was easier
i think as um
we had kids that naturally meant that
life changes
a bit anyway and you don't necessarily
want the same thing so that just kind of
helps
reframe what you're what you why you're
getting up and doing what you're doing
but i think that i don't i think i'm
i've always been quite good at
not taking anything recruitments are
really up and down and it can be really
tough
it can be really mentally challenging um
to
to keep yourself going when you know you
face huge amounts of rejection each and
every day in this job and it's um
that can be really really too it could
be too much for some people and i think
that
if you if you don't if you can just not
attach yourself
to it so much and worry less about the
the
outcomes all the time and just i think
you've got to try and be a bit present
and enjoy
what you're doing each and every day
rather than worry about what hasn't
happened or what might happen if you can
just try and stay in
the moment a bit more that can that can
help but it's um
yeah i think you just got to kind of i
think it would help to sit and
think about your why regularly yeah um
because it does change yeah i think yeah
thank you for sharing that um so fgr
group then
let's talk about this obviously next 30
minutes let's sort of unpack this so
obviously um we saw i i sort of brushed
over it but
overall you spent most your time in in
one recruitment business right so
what would you come worried about moving
to fjr
like because yeah cause i'm sure robert
half became
your like you were just super
comfortable there right you knew people
you've been there for a long time
like what was you what was you most
worried about joining
fjr well i think it was a reasonably
it was probably an easier transition
than it might have been so much as you
know there's people
that i work with today that i've worked
with over the years anyway
um so there's a bit of a comfort blanket
there
still somewhat yeah um i think the
biggest fear for me was
um i'd spend a lot of time
in a in the latter part you know before
joining fjr in a non-billing role where
um i haven't had to be responsible for
personal
production um and so i think the biggest
fear is you know
am i gonna be able to go and make any
money yeah and that's that was the
scariest thing i think
you can um spend lots of time you know
getting a someone that has no experience
in helping them and
going on that journey with them so
they're making the first placement uh
becoming successful
and you know reaching certain milestones
but when you're then
back to the wall and you think jesus i
haven't got any clients and i've got no
you know candidates where am i going to
start and you could you could question
yourself
when reality is you you've done it for
years you should you should be able to
do it and but i think that was scary
that was scary
thinking [ __ ] where do i start yeah and
i'm sure
and i'm sure you came with like a nice
hefty salary as well you're not uh
you're not rushed trainee coming through
the door i think that all of us that are
enjoying
all right yeah i think all of us are
joined have you know had a reasonable
amount of time in the industry so
you've got a fair target on your head i
suppose when you do when you do start so
i think that um
and i think that you know the ultimately
in in the business that we're in we've
got a
we've got to grow because it you know
economies of scale mean that
we need to utilize the um the skill set
that each of us have
you know sort of built up to to balance
that risk a little bit
um but yeah certainly joining it's uh
it's cannot be um
yeah first and foremost because we
didn't you know i joined and there was
two others
in the business um in london to begin
you know at the same time and
you know we had no clients pretty much
building the yeah had no clients yeah
so let's let let's talk about this then
let's unpack this because
this is sort of um an area that a
lot of recruiters are really interested
in okay so i guess
firstly i guess my first question for
you is what did you
you speak like you're speaking about in
the right way but like what did you do
firstly to make sure like
your ego didn't get in the way and be
like i'm [ __ ] i was an
ad not too long ago i shouldn't be like
doing this blah blah blah i guess you
thought about that before you joined but
like
did you have to work through that and
just i guess have that dialogue of like
th
this is part of the process and does it
do because i feel like
you can get to a certain level and be
like yeah like i'm i don't want to be
doing that or spending time on doing
that
yeah do you have to do much of that no i
think i think i'd made a conscious
decision that that was what i wanted to
do so i think i made peace with it
beforehand i think that
um you know i knew um
i think when i i think the frustr when i
first left for behalf of
what i had in my head of what i wanted
to do and again that evolved slightly
but
but i wanted to be probably back in a
more client-facing role less of a sort
of pure
sort of managing leadership role and i
think that um
so it kind of made sense to me but
i think just yeah you just gotta get on
with it i don't think there's any magic
formula to it is there you kind of
i didn't have to have a word with myself
i'd wear themselves
on the phone and do stuff but because
nobody else is going to do it for you
and that's the
that's a bigger challenge isn't it
you're used to having yeah
you burned the boats didn't you you
joined the company where there there's
no other option
yeah really like so so talk what was
what ended up being
what was the the strategy then talk to
us about because a lot of people
may have may have to go through this
right where they built up markets or
they've ended up in a non-billing
position then they've joined the
business which they're really excited by
want to do right
by what what ended up being the approach
so you now had to go and win clients
that was the first thing that we needed
to be doing
how did you go about that let's just get
a bit practical with it like how did you
try and leverage the network that you've
built up over time like
what was the approach yes well i think i
i kind of spent some time
going back over you know who who i'd
worked with in the past who are who i've
helped in the past
thinking about um people that you've
positively impacted candidates and you
know place them in roles and
i guess that becomes a start point of
people that you can go talk to
um what was the conversation just really
quickly so it's a button but was it like
hey i've just joined this company this
is what we're trying to do
wanted to reconnect i wouldn't like what
you up to but like is that
what the conversation was yeah as simple
as that depending on the person yeah
it's just um
i think if you're always approaching
i think people yeah i think that's that
it's as simple as that it's just you
know calling and reconnecting and
talking to it and
what's what i'd urge people not to do is
i think you've got to try if
if that is going to be something that
you do later on you know go back burn
your boats as you say
try not to burn them too much maybe
maybe do stay in contact with some of
the people that you've
you've you've kind of helped and worked
with over the years it's um
then you don't have to start right from
scratch but i think you know
you just go towards people if you're you
know you've helped them in the past most
people
inherently want to help other people and
i think if you if you uh
reach out you're honest with them
explain what you're doing and why you're
doing it
um how you might better add some value
to them then you know not every door is
going to suddenly open for you but
there's a start point yeah yeah
what's the next steps well i think you
then um
i think engaging with your market um
i think you got to work out where you
what you what you're trying to play for
and become quite
um focused on that as a as a niche or an
area so
for me it was sort of finance senior
finance
um in financial services and then more
than that
private equity um you know asset
management
trying to pick a few markets that you
that you've got knowledge of that you
know that you could add some value to
and then sort of networking through
the the people that you would be placing
and and talking to so for me that was
senior finance people so i'd be going
and talking to finance directors cfos
um understand and just having frank
conversations with them about what their
what their own aspirations are
challenges
once you start getting into the flow of
understanding your the the network that
you want to be involved in and
understanding
moving who's not talking to them it just
kind of snowballs isn't it it's not
what what what do you what did you lead
with though out of inter
like i'm trying to just go quite
granular here but i think like
what why so if you re so if you're early
on
that journey and then you yeah you've
mapped out what you're focusing on who
you want to be connecting and networking
with
like why would i give you my why would i
spend time with you
like what like i don't know out of
interest like are you just leading with
hey this is sort of the area that i
focus on
how open would you be to be talking to
talk about the market at the moment like
why what was the reason for them to
speak to you i think if you've
um it's always easier if you've got
something to talk to them about
particularly you've got some
some you know positions to talk to them
about or
um particularly networking with um
candidates i think i think generally
people that are further along in their
career
have a better view of what they do and
don't want to do and so i think
recruitment can be easier when you're
dealing at a more
senior level than when you're dealing at
a more transactional level um
and i think that just reaching i think
if
it probably helps that if you're
reaching out someone on linkedin i guess
i've
got i've been in the industry quite a
long time so i think that probably
has helped me and that someone might
think well this person might be able to
help me
on my journey they might be worth
talking to so that you kind of
if i was starting completely from
scratch i think it's harder but i think
because i've got
a background in the industry for you
know 18 odd years now that
i think it probably opens up a few doors
um a little easier but yeah i just i
just talk to people and i'm just
inquisitive
and i just um you know ask them about
what they're doing now what they want to
do next and what what could i
what could i keep them abreast of what
could i um
check in with them what could i bring to
the table to them
and i think that those sort of general
conversations
open up and you just find angles to go
out when you're in the flow of that
conversation it's
um so what
what what's ended up being like your
most effective way of winning business
then
over these last couple of years have you
been as you've been building this market
out
um i think that um talking to
talking candidates first and foremost
hearing what's going on looking at
you know companies that they've it's
really simple stuff looking at companies
that worked out where they're leaving
you know
finding just general yeah basic
recruitment stuff
i guess the stuff that we that i've not
done as well and probably need to focus
more because it's different to how i was
when i was recruiting years ago is the
branding and the kind of
content and i think that's something
that um
that i definitely haven't mastered um
okay and would you
work more on that um but i think yeah
mike for me it's always been about just
um
going talking to people and just
spotting where you know if you know the
market that you're going after and
you're spotting
candidates that are active knowing that
clearly there's going to be
opportunities coming up in their firms
if they leave
targeting those businesses those hiring
managers it's um
yeah pretty basic stuff i think it's not
sure but but from uh but the content
stuff i think is probably the stuff that
where you can um
what did you end up billions what did
you end up doing billions wise then
first year last year yeah well
i joined in the march and um by the end
of the year
done about 120 i think so it wasn't
didn't knock it out the ballpark
um but i was i was happy because i'd got
some runs on the poor daddy doors
um but yeah it's um it's been a
rollercoaster isn't it because it i mean
we started in 2018
mid march april 2018 and then um
came 2019 was was good and then we've
had a
a weird a weird year or so since so it's
been uh
it's been interesting yeah for sure no
really interesting i guess what um i
know i know it sounds like
really simple and stuff but this is this
is what people are interested in i guess
on on that like what because i'm sure
you've seen this in
colleagues or maybe less experienced
people i know you said what i just kept
on doing was yeah speaking to people
building relationships seeing where i
come out of value and doing
those things but like what did you do
how do you maintain like a long-term
mind [ __ ] mindset you know
towards it because like you we started
at the beginning of
this call and your journey was very
outcomes focused and you had to close
people on that call then
do you know what i mean like what what
do you keep an eye on to make sure that
things are progressing in the
right direction and those types of
things i think he
i think i don't think you're going to
win everyone over are you and i think
you've got a
the ones that you build that you connect
with
um are the ones that i would focus more
on trying to nurture those relationships
with
um i think i'm i'm i've been doing it
long enough to know that i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna win everything and there's
some some doors you can keep knocking on
that you won't get into
and others that will open for you more
quickly and i think that talking to
the ones that you kind of connect with
that genuinely have
an opportunity to potentially help you
at some point or you be of
help to them um are the ones that
i would i would focus on nurturing more
at the expense of others
i think it's just yeah as simple as that
just um you you know i think when you're
gonna
when you get on with someone and i think
that's a big part of it you've got to be
able to
get on with people and i think if you
the ones that you know if i make a call
and i get on
and there's a bit of a nibble there or
you kind of you know there's some
commonality or you've spotted something
that
you you know an interest or something
that you can build some rapport with
that you can then
and and then you have a good call with
them i would i would make sure i die
rise to to go back to them i try and
have something to to help them or
have something that could add value that
i could go back to them with i think
that the challenges is that most people
are getting
spoken to by recruiters so many times
that um
over the course of a week maybe if
they're in a senior
position that it's tough to be memorable
isn't it and i think you
you you know you've got to you've got to
have a bit of a strategy of what you're
going to
um what you're going to go back to them
with so i think i'd always
in my head try and think of you know
maybe a
a progression of calls if it was
completely cold of
you know maybe talking about themselves
first what their career aspirations are
maybe
running a job past them on another call
maybe
um calling them with a with
a job that's maybe not quite right for
them that you're asking for a referral
or
you know having a bit of progression and
each time trying to build into that some
extra
um
context yeah that's going to just help
you get over the line um
sure meeting and solidifying it
so what um so talking about more like
you said yeah obviously
i didn't realize that starting 2018 and
then obviously a year of
that being um obviously uh during covert
so like
what obviously as we come to the end
here what's really helped you
i guess over the last 12 16 months
um deal with the the challenges mentally
over the last 12 or so months i uh i
dropped
uh john a note around what questions
you'd like me to ask
russ and he said you're someone that's
always seems to sort of have
their head on their shoulders or are
able to put themselves back up so just
just curious to hear
yeah what what sort of helped you uh
ride the roller coaster
over the last six times that's a good
question i think it's um
i think part of it is just who you are
right and some people can
um you know are less affected by stuff i
think i generally am someone that will
see
positive in most things um or
opportunity in most things or you know
just learning in
in stuff so i don't think i naturally
i'm i'm not naturally someone that gets
down that much and i think that i've got
i'm
like i've mentioned earlier i'm good at
compartmentalizing and i
recognize that you know work isn't work
is work and it's something i love doing
but it's
it's my job and it's a you know it's not
my life but i think that
having them having interests and
and good relationships and
friends and social stuff outside of work
i think keeps you
is what actually keeps you you know on
the right path i think that
you know you having a good environment
to work in is good and clearly it's been
a tough
a tough 12 18 months for for everyone
and certainly for
some people it's been massively tough um
thankfully um and touchwood i wasn't
overly
affected by it really in in so much as
you know i haven't
go through a pandemic i didn't lose
anyone close to me i was kind of
you know luckily not affected in that
way um and as a business we managed to
we've managed to carry on and and whilst
it wasn't where
you know how we'd exactly want it to be
it's and it's knocked us back a little
bit on our
plan and um journey that we're on it's
um
you know i think when you frame it like
that and there is perspective you know
we've
we've come out of it all right you know
we're all healthy we're we've
got jobs we've got our families are okay
then i think you kind of
you've got to be able to see that you
know that in itself is a positive thing
and it's
um you know there is more to life you
just gotta
enjoy the moment i think it's um
and if you don't i think it's easy to
start worrying about what has happened
you know what hasn't happened what might
happen but a lot of that might not
happen
so you just got to get better at you
know not not try not to
recognize when you know the voice in
your head is is stressing you out and
um giving you back i mean
this constant dying of stressing you
when the reality is you know
that's not you don't have to listen to
it you might hear it but you don't have
to listen to it and youtube
yeah no i love that yeah perspective and
i think
yeah i think yeah making sure that
you're not someone that puts their whole
sort of self-worth and identity
as work yeah it massively helps doesn't
it i think i think
it does because i think it can come
crashing down then can't if you're if
you put
everything into that and then something
happens you know
you know it goes badly or you you know
someone else leaves that you're really
close to that you you know affects you
then your whole
you know world can come tumbling down so
i think you've got to have
balance and um that could be tough i
think certainly when you're
um starting out i know but i think
you've got to force yourself to
to try and have balance i think it's i
think that's massively massively
important to you yeah
i think that that's the thing not
everyone has the the sort of privilege
of having a great support network but i
think that's
that's one of the most sort of valuable
things that i think
you can't always see see
like we were talking about football
earlier in the euros and stuff i would
probably say that
sort of most high performing sports
people
um if you were to sort of uncover from
the podcast stuff
i listen to most of the time a lot of
them will say that the sacrifices and
the hard work they've gone through was
only possible because of the support
network yeah they went through do you
know what i mean and i think
i think in today's world if you listen
to this and you don't feel like you've
got that then we're actually
sort of hearing um russ talk listeners
podcast will help but actually
you you will only be a message away from
connecting with like-minded people that
yeah may come relate to you and stuff
like that but i think you've you've
definitely got to go out your way to try
and build that if you don't have that
i think you do there's lots of resource
out there isn't there so i think i think
it's you know the touch of a button
there's lots
of good stuff out there and there are a
lot of like-minded people it's just um
lifting your head up above the noise and
and recognizing it and and
uh yeah but i do that's that's my i
think that's
one of the most important things is
being able to have you know
having outside interests and not
everything focused on working what is an
industry that's really
you know it's a tough industry at times
and if you're not enjoying it it could
be a horrible place because of the
constant barrage of um
of rejection that you you potentially
face on a day-to-day basis and if you
can't
deal with that it could be a lonely
place but for sure
so how as we come to the end here then
how how are you feeling about the future
of recruitment
what does that look like for you
obviously you've been in the industry
for a while now yeah
i think it's a future i think it's
positive i think there's
um there's still i think it's a massive
industry it's a massive
um you know contributes a lot to the to
the economy
you're helping people find new
opportunities that um
you know i think it's a a massively
important industry and i think having
worked in it a long time i can't you
know i really enjoy what i do and i
really enjoy the industry i think that
clearly there'll be some potential for
it to change and evolve
and i think you know being specialist
is important i think um not too
generalist i think maybe for
i i don't think i don't think we're ever
going to get completely replaced by
you know robots or anything like that i
think the um i think the reality is it's
a people industry and i think that
um i think people
i think you know i think when hiring
people always
respect and value
uh um that sort of input that
a recruiter can provide i don't think
will it i don't think you know there's a
lot of talk sometimes about it
disappearing or being uh you know
certainly maybe at the transactional
level but
i can't see that completely i think that
it will be it will evolve and i think
that
um but i think that we
that human element is tough to replicate
without
having humans involved in it i think
that for that reason it will it would
evolve but it won't
it won't disappear it's too too big in
industry and i think that um
but i think that being being a
specialist in your market is is
massively important
and you know maybe a narrower focus but
deeper in what you do
sure how how do you think we can
change change like him change the
perception where sort of
young young russ has gone i want to get
into recruitment rather than i want to
get into sales
yeah um
would you would you be happy if your
children end up working in recruitment
that's all we did i debate that all the
time she's like absolutely yes yeah
oh god no maybe not because of the
challenges and ups and downs that you
have but
the reality is i look at um
you know our our life and i think we've
had a we've we've got it pretty good so
i think that um
yeah i think i'd be happy for them too i
think that um i think ultimately they've
got to do what they want to do and
and what yeah you know what they what
they want to go after but um
but yeah that's a tricky one isn't it i
think i i think there's um
i think people misjudged how much value
we we offer as an industry
um and i think it is a really important
um job i think that you know without us
a lot of the economy would
be um you know that helping people to
progress in their career and and connect
them with opportunities that can be
life-changing for them i think that's a
really powerful thing and i think it
again it's perspective isn't it it's how
you frame it
[Music]
i think it's an important part an
important role that we play so i yeah
i don't know yeah nothing to be
embarrassed about i think it's uh
um you know you can you can massively
impact your earnings you can be
on uh you know you can when i look at
over the years you think blimey is you
know you're placing some people that
i guess that can help you frame it if
you're placing people and um that are
i've spent years going to university or
other industries to get to a point you
know you think that
you know maybe doctors who have to train
so long and go to university for so long
to earn a level of income that
you could do that in recruitment in a
you know in a couple of years and
i think if you absolutely knocked it out
the ballpark and there's not
many industries i guess that you could
go do that um so i think it's you know
it's uh i like it but maybe not everyone
does
look final um question
for you russ is what what what's the
what's the ultimate goal for your
recruitment career moving forward
um i think that you know certainly we've
got some goals
for the business today um the journey
that we're going on
i don't think i don't know whether i'll
be around for 25 years to
go on john's mission of 25 locations
over 25 years but
but certainly um you know i'm still
enjoying
building teams and and doing recruitment
and growing with it i think
um maybe i don't think too far that you
know
that far ahead i don't know i mean as
long as i'm enjoying what i'm doing on a
day-to-day basis and you know we've got
some milestones that we're looking to
reach
within the company then we'll be going
on the right track
yeah nice look russ been absolute
pleasure love love your mindset i think
it's
you've been on a great journey and yeah
i love how positive and passionate you
are about
recruitment as a whole so thanks uh
thank you for having me